as a professional filmmaker and
photographer Tom Campbell pursues light
in motion but under the sea he must also
predict the behavior of a wild animal
there's an area that you can't call the
shot you don't know what the animal is
going to do so you make a calculated
risk and you depend on your experience
and your training and your abilities of
photographer but you've always got that
overwhelming desire to get that picture
Ningaloo reef Western Australian whale
sharks are the largest fish in the sea
and can grow to more than 30 feet long
to showcase their enormous size Tom
needs something or someone in the frame
that someone is aedra Russ who didn't
learn to scuba dive until she turned 50
the trip to Australia was a great way to
start my diving experience I knew it was
going to be something sterling and
exciting as a seasoned professional tom
knows he can't force the magic but he's
always ready
suddenly he sees his chance there's a
shark starting to swim away we suddenly
saw he opened up his mouth in this
school of yellow fish that was below him
moved right up into the center of his
mouth Tom and aedra kick into high gear
and swim hard to overtake the whale
shark she's swimming as hard as you can
and I needed to catch up with the shark
pushing the camera housing and while I
was swimming I had to set the distance I
had to set the f-stop to the light
factor and I had to get everything set
up on the lens just right I swam ahead
of the shark he got to the point where I
could turn around with just enough time
to squeeze the shutter so I got one shot
squeeze it off and that was it
Tom's single frame proved to be a winner
the light was right the animal was there
the diver was in position I got that
split second that captures some kind of
magic and it was a killer shot